[Music]
let's go to grace in grand rapids
michigan
what's up grace
oh not much how about you you know i was
gonna say we're saving the world but
we for sure aren't
um
i'm running a middling podcast over here
in nashville tennessee but i'm glad to
be talking to you what's going on
okay so um
about a month ago
i
woke up to knock on my door from a state
trooper saying that my husband was in a
car wreck
yikes what happened
he was on his way to work
and
a woman blew through a stop sign
and got him pretty good
oh man i'm so sorry
so where where is he at now how is he
uh
at the time he was in critical condition
which is
something nobody wants to hear
um you have little ones
yes we have um
three little ones five and under so it's
pretty busy around here grace i'm so
sorry
yeah
um
he has severe brain damage due to it
okay
um
he is currently in a nursing and rehab
facility
right now to
try to get him back on his feet
as much as possible
is he awake
he is awake
does he have speech and eye movement and
auditory and sensory stuff
his if movement is getting much better
and they just started speech therapy
with him this week okay does he
recognize you when you're there
we think so
um he especially will try to move his
mouth when his parents are in the room
and grandparents okay
and especially the kids that was
when the kids came to visit him that was
the first time he actually was crying
um
you know that's a really remarkable sign
right
oh yes
yes um
there's so much even just in little
things that god has been showing that
uh he's still here for a reason you know
we keep hearing he should have died
he should have died on the operating
table he should have this but he's still
here
i'm so sorry um so how can i help you
today i'm so sorry
man thank you
um
[Music]
the biggest thing right now is
it's gonna be at least two to five years
hopefully
before he comes home
there is a possibility he might not come
home again
the kids have been
wondering when daddy is coming home
especially our oldest who's five
i know they're going through a traumatic
disappearance just the fact of daddy not
being there
and i'm just wondering how to help them
in that
oh yeah man oh man oh man
i'm so sorry grace
thank you
so
there's a lot here and
if you and i were just talking in person
i'd probably spend the next 10 minutes
just in a hug
who's walking alongside you with this do
you have family do you have friends that
are connected with you guys in any way
so both of our families are pretty big
so there's probably a total of like 40
family members alone
so you got the opposite it's like you
just need a glass of water and you're
getting a fire hose right
people have been coming out work we
didn't even know existed um
we honestly have more people taking care
of us than we know what to do with
and reports introverts so that's that
kind of makes it even more hilarious oh
geez louise
so
people have been giving us meals and
asking what they can do around the house
child care
anything basically we needed
so um
i i think i've talked about this on this
show but um
my oldest and best friend on planet
earth um was
one of his friends ran a stop sign was
um
hit by a car and um
uh we spent some some
multiple days and nights sleeping on icu
floor and um went through the whole
tbi recovery process and all that stuff
and everything's different now 20 years
later everything's different and
we still obviously are in contact almost
every day but um
while i've never been married to anybody
i don't have kids that's a whole other
layer and level
that stunned
just hit by a bus feeling that you have
oh my gosh my heart breaks
um
so when it comes to kids we can just
focus on that one today and then i want
if if you'll
if you're okay with it over the next
couple of weeks next couple of months i
want to keep checking in with you
um i've just been down this road and i
would love to just check in with you
okay and make sure anything you need um
i mean holler at us and you're gonna
have more people around you
giving you
bonkers advice and telling you what you
should be doing and how you should be
doing it and all that stuff and
sometimes just having a neutral
person to call and just say what in the
world
i want to make sure that you know that
we're always going to be here with you
thank you when it comes
let me put it this way um this is a
month ago you said
yes okay
over the next 30 to 60 days
you're gonna be able to breathe again
and my guess is maybe a couple of days
here and there for an hour or so but my
guess is you haven't fully breathed yet
and when you hear things like it could
be two to five years there's a part of
you that where that registers and a part
of you it could be a thousand years or
hey we're gonna go to mars right for all
i
mean
it feels like you're hearing some of
this stuff underwater
right yeah and then some days you
surface and you wake up and you've slept
a little bit deeper than you have and
you look over and he's not there it all
comes back like a giant tidal wave
and then you got three little kids that
you gotta feed and go to the bathroom
and they're asking questions like
where's daddy and i miss daddy and one
of them will just start crying and
yelling and
then it becomes really hard to breathe
am i saying it about right
yes and i did have a talk with the two
oldest
that you know everybody said right now
just because daddy is not here we all
miss daddy we want him to come back
and they have expressed you know they're
sad too because they miss daddy of
course um but they have a little little
album each pictures of them and daddy
playing and so they'll look through that
before they go to bed and it helps them
kind of
just seeing pictures of him comforts
them a little
um having them well so let me back out
one of the greatest things you can do
for them
is to tell them the truth
to not hide your grief from them
don't over share
but they're a part of this process with
you
and one of the things that we often try
to do is protect our kids and in a
situation like this this is trauma that
most people will never understand
when they cry we say it's going to be
okay and it's not it's not everything's
different
and when we cry we need to we go in the
other room
and
they feel crazy
if we do that
and so in the days that you cry and
they're in the room
put your arms out and say can you can we
snuggle
and though and you can just say i'm
missing daddy and that is a lifeline to
a kid
we've had lots of snuggles and they
definitely have seen me cry and they
know why they just say i miss daddy too
and i'm like
yep
and the challenge here's the other
challenge
that they don't become your comfort
blanket right
they can't fill that gap for you and
sometimes it's they are the next closest
thing to him right and it's easy to make
them
like they become your support blanket if
you will and so making sure you've got
adults so the number one thing when i
when folks say what can i do for my kids
in a moment like this i tell them you
make sure you're taking care of you
that you're greeting that you've got
people around you that you're sleeping
that you're eating that you're going for
walks that you're moving your body that
you're doing those things that are going
to keep your heart and head as clear as
they possibly could be while you're
trying not to drown in grief
right so we've made my sisters and
sisters-in-law have been making sure i'm
eating drinking
and that they get
people around me when they're not there
so
you're good
so here's the second thing
draw boundaries and do not apologize i
can't tell you the number of people who
i've talked to over the years who have a
loved one pass away or in a car wreck or
they get a cancer diagnosis and their
full-time job becomes taking care of
everyone around them
making sure they're all okay right
and
you now know that
you have become a beacon to other people
your husband's become a beacon to people
that you all love that life is fragile
and it can go away at any moment and you
can just be driving to work and somebody
runs a stop sign and it's all over right
or that life turns on a dime
and people don't know what to do with
that and they need you to make them
feel like it's all going to be okay
and i need you to hear me say that's not
your job
your job is to take care of you and to
love your kids and so when you get 8 000
texts a day
you can feel free as a bird to respond
to none of them
zero of them you don't owe anybody that
you don't owe anybody
um thank you notes for their meals you
don't owe anybody
you know what i mean like i'll come over
and clean up your house or mow your you
don't know anybody that
you owe you
the opportunity to begin to process this
and heal and you owe your husband
just a hand to hold right now and your
kids and your kids and your kids does
that
i want you to feel as free as possible
to set strong boundaries and say thank
you and then go on and
accept the help
yes that's that's been the most
difficult for me because i'm the giver
not the receiver so all this has been
very humbling there we go games change
now sister right
so if someone wants to mail your lawn
rock on mow it somebody or you know
what's awesome you're gonna have one or
two family members who are like super
uber go-getters you can sit with them
and say here's what i need you to do i
need you to schedule lawn care for the
next year
and they will that'd be such a gift for
them and and you can tell i don't want
to cook for the next 11 years
set it up and they will be like yes and
they'll get a spreadsheet out every
every family's got that person right um
you can give them that gift and that you
are gonna have to learn just to say
thank say thank you and say yes i need
some help i need some help with some
laundry i need some help with my kids
does that make sense
yes actually his aunt has been in charge
of the meal train and child care getting
that scheduled and my father-in-law's
been
taking care of just anything that needs
done around the house getting
everything on autopay for bills and
setting up things and all that stuff so
great great great great great great
great how are you guys financially
helped and i know how to how to
deal with how are you guys financially
we are okay um we had that three to six
months
of expenses saved
and
because so many people have been so
generous we have not touched that at all
great did you have short-term or
long-term care insurance
that is in the works as we speak but he
your husband had that at his employment
yes okay fantastic so so good what a
gift
um
i've been in these situations where
someone's got to go to work on monday
and that's such a gift good good good
good good
all right here is the last little piece
of advice i'll give you
okay for in this again this is all free
so you can you can hang up the phone and
be like well that was a waste of 10
minutes of my life
i want you to practice not feeling
guilty for smiling
and i want you to practice not feeling
guilty for laughing
for taking the kids out to dinner just
y'all for
for going to a movie just y'all for
you're gonna feel guilty that you're not
including parents and grandparents and
cousins
you're going to feel guilty that you're
doing these things and it's going to
feel like you're quote unquote moving on
while your husband's in a hospital bed
you're going to feel guilty when you've
got to pick up all three kids and you're
going to miss one of his pt appointments
and i want you to decide now
i'm going to be at full
at peace
with
trying to however difficult and ugly and
brutal it is
if i see a flower growing up to the
sidewalk i'm going to stop and
acknowledge it because it's beautiful
if something's funny in my house i'm
going to laugh i'm not going to feel
guilty about it just because my
husband's not here okay
the guilt and shame machine will get up
and going in a wild wild way
so i want to make sure you have a
journal of some sort and if i were you i
would over pay for it i'd go get some
fancy pants leather bound something or
other
and i would start a series of letters to
my husband things he misses like when it
just pops in your head a funny joke an
old office episode whatever it happens
to be when you reach over in bed and
he's not there
i want you just to write that down reach
for you tonight you weren't here i miss
you
and um
something hilarious happened today i
missed you
i ruined dinner again and
i can't even warm up leftovers right
and
you would have laughed at me and you
weren't here missed you
had an awesome day at pt today and it
was so good to see you
i have been writing those things down
and
just so that when he is actually able to
read again he'll have something to look
through
and i want your children to to draw in
pictures
children process thing through play
through writing stuff down through
coloring you can color daddy a picture
and maybe that becomes a thing you'll do
once a week or twice a week we're all
going to color daddy a picture we're
going to make them uh um you know get
some grass and gravel i don't know what
kids do they come up with crazy stuff
and know that your five-year-old is
going to have different memories than
your one-year-old right
oh yes those are going to be different
the one-year-old is going to be he's
going to be abstract he's going to be
this floating presence that was sort of
here and not here
and then six months from now it'll have
been you know almost half of that young
child's life
where dad wasn't here or dad was just
that guy in the hospital so every kid's
gonna have different levels of memory
and it will be different for everybody
right
don't put expectations don't compare
your grief don't say well it could have
been so bad no this is hard and awful
and heartbreaking yeah right
don't feel very lonely without him here
it's so lonely
and then his shoes are over there in the
corner and his stupid shirt still wadded
up in the bathroom right it's all still
there
and there's those days it's so
comforting to see that stuff and those
days that it is
it is so heartbreaking to see that stuff
right
yeah who knew actually doing his laundry
would be so hard yeah you know
well it's always hard
it's always hard but it's a special
right especially right now
um
look those doctors in the eye
and tell them that you love them and
you're grateful for them
and pass along that gratitude where you
can is is a healing gift for you too and
just know you're going to be healing
from this
forever for a long time so you're not
going to try to outrun the grief you're
not going to try to outrun the healing
it's going to be little tiny steps every
single day
yeah
your kids are really blessed to have you
grace
and what an incredible family incredible
family
make sure you have non-family friends
that you can be angry with and cuss your
brains out with and scream it and be mad
at god with if you're a person of faith
that you can just rage through this and
you can cry with and you can laugh with
and go get pedicures with and all those
things
make sure you've got people to do this
with because grief demands a witness
and this isn't going to make sense for a
long time that's not really the goal the
goal is survival the goal is
learning how to breathe again
the goal is making sure those kids and
you are eating and walking and moving
and
the goal is holding that old man's hand
and the
the
advancements they've made with tbi is
just something to behold and so i would
hold every bit of optimism and hope
that
two to five years becomes
you know six to nine months
that we don't know how long we don't
know how long becomes suddenly he sits
up and says i got a headache and i've
seen that a few times with with
people that i'm close to
so
keep out hope keep out optimism don't be
afraid of the grief don't feel guilty
for laughing
and we will be thinking about you grace
we will be thinking about you stay in
touch and we'll talk to you soon